وننتقل الى ملف التصعيد بين ايران وطالبان
افغانستان ففي ايران تشهد هذه الحدود
الشرقيه مع افغانستان توترا لم يرقى بعد
لمستوى الصراع لكن المخاوف من التصعيد
تسيطر على الموقف حادث حدودي هكذا وصفت
ايران التماس بين الدولتين على اثر اطلاق
حرس الحدود الافغاني النار واندلاع
اشتباكات ادت لسقوط ضحايا من جانبه حذر
وزير الداخليه الايراني احمد وحيد حركه
طالبان من التصعيد ودعاها للتوجيه حرس
الحدود لمنع اي تصعيد محتمل بين الطرفين
وعلى الرغم من تبادل الاتهامات والمسؤوليه
حول بدء اطلاق النار الا ان الطرفين تعهد
بالتهدئه لكن حقيقه ما الذي حدث على
الحدود بين البلدين الاسبوع الماضي
الروايه الايرانيه تقول ان قوات افغانيه
في اقليم نيمروز باشرت باطلاق النار على
الطرف الايراني وتحديدا على مركز الشرطه
باستخدام اسلحه خفيفه لتؤكد انها اتبعت
البروتوكولات الحدوديه باطلاق انذار لاحقا
ردت طهران باطلاق النار تجاه قوات حرس
الحدود التابعه للطالبات على الجانب الاخر
اختلفت روايه طالبان التي اكدت ان القوات
الايرانيه هي من بدات باطلاق قذائف هاون
على مطار مدينه زرنج حادث الاسبوع الماضي
ادى الى سقوط ما لا يقل عن ثلاثه قتله من
الجانبين واغلاق الحدود بين البلدين وتبعه
حشد عسكري من الطرفين وسط مخاوف من تصعيد
التوتر
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات